هذا هو الملعب النهائي للمبيعات ،
وهو هجوم مصمم للغاية على أحد
التلال في كوريا الجنوبية ، حيث كانت
الدبابات K2 مدافع الهاوتزر أباتشي
وطائرات بدون طيار
تربط الهجوم أو لعرض ما يقرب من 2000
جمهور قوي من الجنرالات
والمسؤولين الحكوميين والمشترين المحتملين من أكثر
من عشرين دولة حول الولايات المتحدة.
عالم جديد من أكبر صادرات كوريا الجنوبية على
الإطلاق للأسلحة إلى بولندا
تقدر قيمتها بحوالي 15 مليار دولار
وفقًا لمسؤولين
صانعي الأسلحة في كوريا الجنوبية
شجعوا الآن تعهد الرئيس يينسوكيول
بأن تصبح بلاده
رابع أكبر مصدر للأسلحة في العالم
يحاول تحقيق المرتبة الرابعة.
لن تكون مهمة سهلة
ولكنها شيء يجب متابعته على
الساحل الجنوبي الشرقي للبلاد في
مدينة تشانغ ، وفازت شركة Hyundai rotem
بتجميع واختبار
شحن K2 4
، حيث ترسل ما يقرب من 1000 إلى بولندا
بصفقة مع دولة الناتو في  الوقت الذي كانت
فيه أوكرانيا التي تمولها وتجهزها
دول الناتو تحارب
الغزو الروسي
تقول وزارة الدفاع البولندية إن هذه
الدبابات K2 ستحل جزئيًا محل
دبابات الحقبة السوفيتية التي تبرعت بها لأوكرانيا
في القتال ضد روسيا ، كما
يقولون إنهم يتوقعون بدء تسليم الدفعة الأولى من 180
دبابة هذا العام.
تعتقد أن دباباتها K2
أرخص من منافساتها هي
خيار جيد للسعر ويتم
تحديث أداء rk2 باستمرار ، وتتمتع
الدول المنتجة التي تشتري الدبابة
بميزة الاستمرار في
تشغيل السلاح وصيانته
بسعر مناسب
بعد خمس دقائق من الطريق.
دفاع يتباهى بصفقات بمليارات الدولارات
مع تسع دول بما في ذلك
بولندا وأستراليا
، وهو الآن يضع نصب عينيه على
الولايات المتحدة ، حيث إن إنتاج مركبات
إعادة تزويد الذخيرة بالكلاب هاوتزر و K-10
بحد أقصى يمكن لهذا المصنع
وحده إنتاج ما يصل إلى 100
مدفع هاوتزر للكلاب.  عام بين أنظمة الأسلحة الأخرى ،
قيل لنا إن لديهم أيضًا
مخزونًا جاهزًا للعمل والقدرة على
تسليم الأنظمة  السرعة هي المفتاح في هذا
الوقت المضطرب تقول هانوا إن
الإستراتيجية الرئيسية ليست فقط بيع التكنولوجيا الخاصة بهم
ولكن لمشاركتها على المدى الطويل
مع العميل ، فقد ذهبنا إلى
شراكتنا طويلة الأجل في بلدهم
، فإن تركيزنا الاستراتيجي الرئيسي هو
الدخول في
البيئات التشغيلية للسوق ميزة واحدة تتمتع بها
كوريا الجنوبية وفقًا لتجربة الخبراء
في بناء آلات القتال
للطقس القاسي والتضاريس
الصعبة والجيران المخادعين ، فقد أعطانا التهديد الكوري الشمالي
سببًا جيدًا للتأكد من
أن أسلحتنا جيدة
جدًا كدولة ذات عسكرة عالية  دولة
لا تزال من الناحية الفنية في حالة حرب مع
كوريا الشمالية ، لم يتم توقيع معاهدة السلام
الخاصة بها أبدًا ، ومع
استمرار الخدمة العسكرية الإلزامية للرجال
، تعمل الحكومات والشركات المتعاقبة الآن
معًا لتصدير
نتائج تلك العسكرة في جميع أنحاء العالم